my name is still have Sultan I'm from
Iraq and i'm here representing the
global changemakers i personally think
that one thing that needs to be changed
in order to have more jobs in the Middle
East is the fact that the mindset of
what constitutes a job needs to change
as a young person and who has lived her
all of her life in Iraq I found it
difficult to change your mindset that I
need to go to university to have a
degree in order to be able to find a job
but that's not the case because having
some experiences in the Western world
and if we have it out I'd look on the
Western world will see that vocational
training will see that the skills that
can help other people get a job would be
as beneficial as perhaps even more
beneficial from those who have graduated
from University I think that the fact
that there are some cultural issues that
stand in the way but mostly it is about
helping young people helping the new
generation understand that in the 21st
century the focus needs to shift from
from very primitive points of view to
want that extends to outside of the box
young people are making change in the
Middle East they are the driving power
of what what is becoming a democratic
state so it is very important it's
imperative that
leaders of today give wait for the young
people to actually have a voice in the
in the decision-making process even
though in some countries these young
people are not we are not waiting for
the leaders to give them a voice they
are the ones who have taken it so it's
very important to support the youth and
as well as shift the process of thinking
from what from the primitive point of
view to what constitutes a better life
in the 21st century including thinking
of sustaining the idea of the economic
growth from shifting from oil thinking
of the oil thinking of a basic energy to
energy that is sustainable to solar
power and to green energy and